in this video we'll talk about
neutrophil which is a very important
immune cell
neutrophils are most abundant leukocytes
they are component of the innate immune
system neutrophils play crucial roles
against
bacteria neutrophils are highly
phagocytotic and neutrophil levels
increase in the blood when there is an
infection in our body if you haven't yet
subscribed the channel hit that
subscribe button and stay tuned till the
end
so neutrophils are the most abundant
leukocytes and they are the majority of
the leukocyte population they constitute
around 50 to 70 percent of the total
circulating leukocytes
now other than neutrophils the basophils
and eosinophils they are kind of the
minority
so now we understand neutrophils are
damn important for the body and we'll
try to understand why they are important
before that let's talk about the
development of the neutrophils
neutrophils are born in the bone marrow
and they are derived from the myeloid
progenitor lineage
from myeloid progenitors neutrophils
develop in a subsequent step and then
they get secreted into the bloodstream
in the circulation they can survive
several hours and then eventually they
move into the tissue space
now in the tissue space they play
several function in the tissue space
they also die they fight the pathogen so
lot of actions happen in the tissue
space
now let's look at the development of the
neutrophils in bit more details
so from the
myeloblast neutrophil develops in
different stages
it becomes
pro myelocyte myelocyte metamyelocyte
band cells and eventually they become
mature neutrophils you must be wondering
what is the difference in between these
cell types or this
transient cellular states
one point that differentiate between
this cellular
transition state
is the presence of granules
so primary or azurophilic granules are
common in many stages of these
neutrophil development whereas
secretory granules and secondary
granules are more specific towards a
mature neutrophil
that means neutrophil has different type
of granules and they are one type of
granulocyte right
so neutrophils has a zero field granules
also known as primary granules which has
myeloperoxidase
natural serine proteases cathepsin g
protein s3 and many other enzymes
including lysozymes
there are specific granules which has
lactoferrin lysozymes cytochrome b558
collagenase
they also have gelatinous granule which
has cytochrome b558 lysozymes
cd11bnc8 and secretary granules which
has cr1 alkaline phosphatase
and
fmlpr
so this is a vivid description of the
heterogeneity of granules that possessed
by the neutrophil and all of these
secretory contents have different
functions and we would understand that
in a bit more details
so neutrophil invasion is the hallmark
feature of acute inflammation so imagine
you have a small cut in your hand in the
nearby area there would be some amount
of inflammation in a mirror in a minor
quantity and one of the hallmark feature
would be neutrophil in in
neutrophil innervation in that
particular area if you don't know what
is acute inflammation you can watch my
video on acute inflammation
but let's move on
let's say we are struck by a nail
and some of the bacteria that was there
in the rusty nail has entered our body
so neutrophils are the first responders
who can like kind of fade phagocytos
those bacteria and kind of fight them
also other cells such as the resident
macrophages dendritic cells they can
also eat up the pathogen and they can
coordinate with the neutrophils and the
way they coordinate is by secretion of
several cytokines this secretion of
several cytokines especially the
inflammatory cytokines
allows
different changes in the body
one of the change is expression of
surface adhesion molecule in the blood
vessels generally in the blood vessel
neutrophils are
circulates in a rolling fashion
now when there is adhesive expression in
the endothelial wall neutrophil slows
down
and gradually there are several
interactions with the neutrophil
and the
capillary wall and this results in a
slower rolling of neutrophil neutrophils
now slows down and there are certain
cytoskeletal rearrangement happens
in the neutrophil this kind of squeezes
the neutrophil through the narrow
capillary
the narrow gap between the capillary
endothelial cells and ultimately
neutrophil moves out of the blood vessel
and enters the tissue space this process
is also known as diabetes or neutrophil
extravasation
and this process is increased when you
have inflammation a lot of neutrophils
are getting signals from the inflam
inflamed region and they are attracting
more and more neutrophils towards it
neutrophil has entered the tissue space
right now
and now they can see some opponents the
bacteria and now their goal is to kill
those bacteria literally neutrophil
would chase that bacteria until they can
engulf the bacteria and phagocytose them
once phagocytosed that bacteria there
would be lysosomal fusion and the
lysosomal enzymes can actually degrade
the bacteria
alternatively neutrophil has elaborate
mechanism by which they can generate
reactive oxygen species inside the cell
and this reactive oxygen species can
kill and damage the membrane of bacteria
or any other kind of pathogen that has
been in
innervated the body
and thereby
neutrophil can eliminate pathogen
now neutrophil is super important for
the body and in diseases like chronic
granulomatous disease there are
granuloma formation
in chronic
in cgd or chronic
brand new low motors disease
the neutrophils lack the enzyme nadph
oxidase
in absence of this enzyme ros production
is kind of abrogated
and that is why the pathogen killing
efficiency of this neutrophil and many
other
phagocyte phagocytes are decreased and
that's why they kind of create a cluster
around these pathogens and this is known
as granuloma now we understand from a
clinical perspective why it is super
important
neutrophils also take part in antigen
antibody dependent cellular cytotoxicity
if you need to learn this particular
topic in details you can click on the i
button
anyway in short
our
body produces antibody against any kind
of invading pathogen let's say this
bacteria and all these cells including
neutrophils
has the receptors against the fc region
of the antibody
so ultimately they can
bind to these antibodies and engulf this
pathogen and thereby eliminating them
now phagocytosis by neutrophil is a
strong defense mechanism against fungal
infections not only neutrophil protects
our body against bacterial infection but
also for fungal infection they are also
efficient
neutrophil takes part in the type 3
hypersensitivity reaction which is an
immune complex mediated hypersensitivity
reaction
so in that case
immune complexes can circulate in the
blood vessels and somewhere they can
settle down in different locations in
the blood vessels
and that triggers neutrophil to
degranulate and this creates local
inflammation
in those regions and thereby it results
in the harmful effect of type 3
hypersensitivity reaction
anyway
neutrophils are also different in
different ages that means a fresh
neutrophil is very different from a aged
neutrophil in terms of surface
expression of molecules
the surface receptors that are expressed
by a fresh versus aged neutrophils are
widely different that means we can
understand they are really different
even they are mature
also the circulating neutrophils are
really different from one another and
there is a huge heterogeneity in the
neutrophil population depending on where
they end up that means whether they go
to the lung or let's say spleen or the
lymph node
they end up being a slightly different
neutrophil from their counterparts
so this is the latest research that
people are focusing on to identify the
heterogeneity within the neutrophil
population and try to understand whether
there are subgroups which play a
specific function
so in this video we learned several
things about neutrophil like their most
abundant leukocytes we looked at their
role in the immune system we looked at
how they phagocytosis bacteria and
ultimately how they can eliminate
bacteria with the help of ross we also
looked at what happens when neutrophils
ability is compromised and that results
in diseases like cgd
and we also looked at neuro neutrophil
tech parts in
type 3 hypersensitivity and there might
be different sub types of neutrophil in
our body so that kind of summarize the
whole video
all the lecture notes and
flashcards are available in my facebook
page so all the link for the facebook
page is provided in the description
please follow me and like me on facebook
you can also get several dynamic flash
cards for your revision in my facebook
page don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can support my channel on
patreon i'm present in wide variety of
social media feel free to connect i
would be happy to help my courses are
also present in unacademy which is
india's biggest online learning platform
using a code ap 10 you can get a 10
discount on the subscription